[موسيقى]
من ال 94 حتى اليوم ونحن نتحدث عن سعيد
العويران نتحدث عن انجاز السعوديه امام
بلجيكا من اليوم تاريخ جديد يكتب للمنتخب
السعودي من اليوم افضل لحظه في تاريخ
الكره السعوديه هي لحظه تسجيل صالح الشهري
الهدف الاول وسالب الدوسري للهدف الثاني
من اليوم افضل لحظه قمه الكره السعوديه هي
هذه اللحظه التي نعيشها اليوم السعوديه
تنتصر على الارجنتين لديك كلام كثير اقوله
عن الامور التكتيكيه في الملعب ولكن لا
مجال للتيك في حضره التاريخ هذا التاريخ
يكتب هنا يكتب باحرف سعوديه احرف خضراء من
ذهب يكتبها لاعبون المنتخب السعودي اليوم
هنا في قطر امام من امام الارجنتين ميسي
الارجنتين دي ماريا ارجنتين لو تاره
مارتينز كلها هؤلاء اللاعبين الكبار لم
يكونوا كبارا اليوم امام مين امام محمد
العويس امام حسان امام الدفاع السعودي
الرائعه موجود علي البليهي ياسر الشهراني
وغيره من اللاعبين الرائعين جدا اضف الى
ذلك تالق سالم الدوسري والهدف العالمي
الذي سجله اليوم صالح الشهري رائع في راس
البريكان ادوار دفاعيه وهجوميه ممتازه جدا
تبديلات رينار كانت على المسطره كما يجب
ان تكون من البدايه الدفاع في الشوط الاول
في الشوط الثاني نضربهم بهجمه مرتده وهو
ما حدث بالضبط السيناري الذي كان يرجوها
رونالدو حدث في هذه المباراه السعوديه
اليوم فعلتها السعوديه اليوم تالقت
السعوديه اليوم رفعت راس اسيا بعد ان خسرت
ايران بالامس بالسداسيه مقابل هدفين اليوم
السعوديه رفعت راس اسيا تالقت وكتب
التاريخ الجديده لاسيا شكرا لجمهور
السعودي هذا جمهور المتالق الان يمكنكم
رؤيته
حقهم يفرحون من حق هذا الجمهور ان يفرح
اليوم لان منتخبه كتب التاريخ باحرف من
ذهب هنا في قطر محمد العويس كان رائعا جدا
بقيه لاعبي المنتخب السعودي كانوا رائعين
لا يمكنني ان انسى لاعب واحد في هذا
المنتخب من اساسيين واحتياطيين سعود عبد
الحميد كان رائعا في في التعاون مع بابا
غوميز المنتخب الارجنتين دخل مباراه
بطريقه بصراحه غريبه حتى اختيارات
الدفاعيه كانت غريبه مع وجود روميرو
وتمندي على حساب رومارتينز ولكن هذا لا
يعنينا اليوم ما يعنينا هو انتصار
السعوديه يعني هو انتصار الاخضر ما يعني
هو هذا الانجاز التاريخي الذي يكتب اليوم
باقدام سعوديه بلا شك على حساب الارجنتين
وارجنتين بس
[موسيقى]
تكتيكيا دخل المنتخب السعودي بشكل اقرب
لطريقه ال 4231 مع وجود صالح الشهري كم
مهاجم صريح وجود البريكان على الجهه
اليمنى ووجود سالم الدوسري على الجهه
اليسرى كان في عندنا كانه وسلمان الفرج
بالاضافه لعبد الاله المالكي اللي كان
رائع اليوم ايضا وخطط الدفاع المكون من
الرباعي الشهراني والبليه
وتمبكتي والى اليسار كان موجود عندنا
الشهراني وحارس مرمى كان طبعا محمد العويس
اداء السعوديه كان دفاعي جيد في شوط
المباراه الاول
ثلاثه اهداف ملغيه للارجنتين بس داعي
التسلل لان التنظيم السعودي كان رائع اداء
المنتخب السعودي الدفاعيا كان ممتاز جدا
وهذا الامر الذي اثر بشكل جيد وايجابي على
طريقه التعامل مع الهجمات الارجنتينيه
اللي كانت عاجزه بصراحه امام هذا الهجوم
امام هذا الدفاع عفوا عايشه امام هذا
الوسط
الوسط الذي كان رائعا كان مميزا لذلك
اعتقد انه المنتخب السعودي النجح بكل
المقاييس في التعامل مع الهجوم الارجنتيني
طلع دقائق الشوط الاول في دقائق شوط
الثاني كان في حاله من تغيير الاسلوب كان
في نوع من المجازه في الهجوميه وفعلا نجحت
هذه المجازفه بتسجيل صالح الشهري للهدف
الاول وبعد ذلك سالم الدوسري والهدف
العالمي على طريقه اريل روبن بالارتوب
البعيده فعلها سالم الدوسري وسجل هدف
الثاني للسعوديه الارجنتين لم تستوعب ما
يحصل لا احد في الملعب كان يصدق ما يحصل
الا 11 لاعب سعوديا هم الوحيدون الذين
صدقوا ان هذا الامر يمكن ان يحدث وان هذه
حقيقه نعيشها اليوم ونجحوا بالحفاظ على
التقدم نجحوا بالتالق نجحوا ب- تحقيق
الفوز التاريخي على الارجنتين الارجنتين
تبديلات كلوني بعض ذلك لم تكن بصراحه
ناجحه تبديل تاكله
لا شيء اخر خلونا ناخذ لقطات من الجمهور
السعودي الان هذا جمهور الرائع الجمهور
السعيد اليوم الذي يكتب التاريخ باحرف من
ذهب
ها هؤلاء هم السعوديون الفاخرون اليوم
بانجاز منتخبهم هؤلاء الذين كتبوا التاريخ
اليوم باحرف من ذهب
هؤلاءهم السعوديون الذين لا يعرفون
المستحيل على ما يبدو في كؤوس العالم وبعد
نكسات طويله نجحوا في تحقيق الانتصار
نجحوا في تحقيق الفوز السعوديه ويوم
للتاريخ السعوديه ويوم للتاريخ وتصبحون
دائما على تاريخ